based on the thumbnail you can probably  tell that this is a short well Jake all  your videos are short you may be yes but  they are not shorts times are changing  and we have to move with the times we  have to be flexible unless  unless I don't have to unless  this was never a short to begin with  jaws North by Northwest horizontal my  videos about poop anxiety will stand  among the legends of Cinema because I  choose horizontal now you may say Jake  this seems like a weird Hill to die on  right well  You Gotta Die sometime the vertical  stuff is weird I think I don't like that  it's different it's cool if other people  do it I guess but I just I just like  horizontal well unless like shorts are  like super profitable or something  because then yeah definitely I will  switch I'd be stupid not to then but but  until then I draw a line in the sand  this  is not weird